[Music]
we know that you have noticed that
michael has not been with us here
this week he wanted us to let you know
that he has tested positive for cobit
he's at home quarantine right now gma's
michael strahan who's not experiencing
severe symptoms
has been out all week how's he doing
he's one of my best friends
he's feeling great and he'll be back up
and at it
soon enough michael's gma colleague
george stephanopoulos had coveted last
year
and co-anchor robin roberts a two-time
cancer survivor
is in a high-risk group robin actually
stayed away
from the studio for a long period of
time because of her situation
it does weigh on you would you know that
you have an underlying condition
they have to be very vigilant about who
they allow into the space
how often um they are getting tested
there was also a covet gear this week at
cbs this morning
do not adjust your television it is 2021
you have not gone back in time
the show's three main hosts were not in
the studio on wednesday
we've had a positive test in our studio
so i'm back home
and out of an abundance of caution gail
king and anthony mason
are social distancing meanwhile media
mogul tyler perry says
he's doing fine after being vaccinated
on camera he talked to gail on tuesday
about his vaccine special
targeting the black community that airs
tonight i've got people who love what i
do and kind of follow me and what i told
them is that
i'm not taking this vaccine because i
want you to take it i want to give
you the information so you can make your
own choices